Коли він приїздить до Варшави
телефонує лише у кафе - подалі від чужого вуха
Суддя Вальдемар Журек відкрито протистоїть атаці
польського уряду на незалежність системи правосуддя
За словами судді, відтоді як він відкрито заявив про свою позицію, за ним почали стежити
Ми перебуваємо у стані війни за верховенство права
Так я якось висловився в одному інтерв´ю
Вони хочуть змінити систему в нашій державі
нашу конституцію простими законами
Протести поки не принесли бажаних результатів
Ось уже кілька днів, як вступив у дію новий закон
згідно з яким польський міністр юстиції має право звільняти суддів без пояснення причин
Для Журека новий закон - це напад на конституцію
У присязі судді я поклався президенту Польщі, що оберігатиму конституцію
Конституція  - це найвищий закон
Ось чому я захищатиму конституцію до кінця
Така мужня позиція має свою ціну
Уже кілька місяців Журека допитують у прокуратурі
Розслідування ведеться формально через численні листи з погрозами, які він отримує
Прокуратура подає це як захист його життя і  здоров'я
Однак сам суддя вважає це лише приводом
аби виправдати втручання у його особисті справи
Я не довіряю прокурору
Я боюсь, що незабаром вони також санкціонують
обшук мого компютера з усією моєю інформацією та контактами
Вже тепер вони перевіряють мої телефонні дзвінки
без мого відома і дозволу
Тим часом Польське антикорупційне бюро
вирішило прискіпливо переглянути фінансові звіти Журека за останні роки
Вони запитують мене, наприклад, скільки грошей я мав на рахунку 5 років тому
Я відповідаю: стільки, скільки зазначено у моїй фінансовій звітності
Але вони продовжують копати далі
5 тисяч злотих? Більше 5ти тисяч? Чи, може, менше?
Я ж цього не можу точно пам'ятати
Провладні ЗМІ повідомляють про "неймовірні статки судді Журека"
Політологи вбачають у цьому типову медіа-атаку проти незгодних з політикою уряду
Атака в медіа зазвичай триває кілька місяців
Після цього запроваджують нові правила, які мають щось змінити
Так само відбувалося зі свободою ЗМІ та неурядовими організаціями
Спочатку кампанія проти когось, а потім, власне, удар
Вальдемар Журек не знає, що буде далі, і хвилюється за свою сім´ю
Однак здаватися він не збирається